es una bola de Victoria para Óscar
temaru fundador y líder del partido Pro
independencia de la Polinesia francesa
quien junto con el diputado y futuro
presidente moetai brotherson obtuvo la
mayoría absoluta en el parlamento en la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
territoriales ambos se apresuraron a
reafirmar su deseo de separarse de
Francia
es la única vía Si queremos erradicar la
pobreza que corrobea nuestro país
el movimiento independentista cuenta con
el apoyo de la ONU que incluyó a la
Polinesia francesa en una lista de
territorios por descolonizar actualmente
los cinco archipiélagos gozan de cierta
autonomía en Salud Educación y medio
ambiente y París tomó nota públicamente
de la nueva composición política del
territorio
Los Polinesios han votado por el cambio
el gobierno toma nota de esta elección
democrática trabajaremos con la recién
elegida mayoría con compromiso y rigor
para seguir mejorando la vida cotidiana
de nuestros conciudadanos Polinesios sin
embargo darmaná no mencionó la
independencia y solo París podría
decidir sobre un referéndum
estamos entrando en un callejón sin
salida en cuanto al calendario 10 o 15
años
de independencia
[Música]
en su manifiesto los independentistas
afirman que quieren proteger el empleo
local la agricultura y la artesanía así
como fomentar el turismo en caso de
Independencia La Polinesia francesa
tendría que sufragar los mil millones de
euros que Francia paga anualmente en
concepto de profesores policía y
administración